good morning Millennials
I'm here with Olivia do you want to do
you want to hit us with a good morning
have you done it yet I have never done
it give us your best good morning
Melania I feel like you're gonna make
fun of me no it's so much fun here good
night good morning Millennials do you
know whatever minds yeah oh good morning
Megan
I won't blast her last name but we used
to have a principal in high school who
talked like that now that we think about
it he's like good morning Megan last
name last night I used to say that all
the time yeah we subtile a thing yeah
good time but it's so not the same but
it is welcome to the toast
thank you so much for having me I can't
believe I haven't been here before I
know you came to set one phrase yeah
okay so you knew where you were going
when you got here I was hoping that
would be the case yeah we are so happy
to have you you were just jealous oh you
were so requested and you also like were
one of the harder' guests to nail down
listen like I'm a working girl so 9:00
to 5:00 is like my prime time right
but 10:30 is our time it's toast time we
have so many questions for you obviously
you're the talk of the town the toast of
the town
I'm gonna come as hate your phone I'm
turning it on just so that I don't have
to say great but and you like how you're
good I'll be fine okay you're the toast
of the town engage yes an underage Mazel
Tov we're gonna get a close-up of the
ring you guys because we know that's
really what you tuned in to see so how
are you feeling I feel amazing it's just
like such a weird feeling in the sense
that I feels like so overwhelmed with
just like so much emotion but I'm so
happy I'm on such a high and I just like
never want the high to go down has it
sunk in yet like to wake up and remember
that you're engaged you have to remind
yourself no I wake up and remember that
I'm engaged I wake up like excited that
I'm engaged and like me and Zach always
wake up and we're like we're engaged you
know so very exciting it's an exciting
time have you begun the wedding planning
process I have actually Zach and I are v
down to have a pretty short engagement
so we're just sorting through all of the
details now and it's just a super
exciting time for you to for me as well
sisters and funny is life
speak on the show we were talking about
his story about the Kardashians and we
were saying how cute it is that they're
all having babies at the same time which
is what they always wanted like
literally stormy and Chicago were born
within two weeks of each other and I was
about to say it's like us like all kind
of getting married around the same time
but you weren't engaged yet so I bit my
talents what I really want to say it and
now I can take it and here's the thing
if you said it I probably wouldn't have
seen it but people would have read into
it and it would have just caused us [ __ ]
it would have started a post in the
toaster and by the way what I want to
say is now that I am engaged so many
people are just like I've known for so
long I've known for so long because the
reality is is that between everybody's
plans like this has obviously been in
the works for a while right and
obviously a lot of people were in the
know and the fact that like nothing ever
leaked to me I feel like ISM I can't
believe it
we're a tight lipped Bunch like my
friend sandy who's watching like told
her freaking co-worker that she's like
oh my friend olivia is getting engaged
today like just the fact that like
people didn't let didn't spiral is so
beyond me well I mean I tried to tell
like no one because I trust myself but
like once it's outside my body like I
can't control it but she told person
weeks before no no Jo oh that's fine by
then like yeah it's not gonna get to you
in time total today of like how
surprised were you okay and this is what
everybody keeps asking me and what I
will say is I was surprised and I was
not surprised at the same time because I
knew it was coming and the thing was is
that there was only so many days in the
year with everybody being in New York
that it could possibly happen right and
so funny when people are like are you
surprised it's like yes I I communicate
with my man like I know that we're
getting engaged right exactly I knew
that like it was happening soon I didn't
obviously know when but every day that
it could be I had like a little like
tinker in my mind I'm like today could
be the day but I didn't want to be that
type of person who like got a blowout or
like was super like amped up because if
it didn't happen then the only person
you're mad up it's yourself like what do
you say to the person like I'm really
upset with you didn't propose like a
psychotic so I was just like if it
happens great if I have frizzy hair
great like whatever happens I'll be just
so happy that it's happening that it
won't even give a [ __ ] that is such a
good way to look at it and honestly if I
had to guess like I wouldn't have taken
you as that kind of girl like I thought
you would have wanted to be like dry
barred glam squad
like claw nails ready at any moment I
think like when you see that's not a way
to live but I think when you think about
it like sure you want that because you
think that you want that because like
that's just like an image that you have
in your mind but like when it's actually
happening so like we could go into the
story because I'll tell you exactly
because basically what happened was we
have dinner together every Friday night
everybody knows that and because of
summer Friday's like without a Sabbath
yes Shabbat and because it was over the
summer recently Zach and I would always
hang out like every Friday afternoon
because we both had summer fridays to
some extent mostly we just both took
them so usually we would just like hang
out before and then go to dinner and so
when he was like I'll meet you at your
apartment and I was like great and then
we'll go to dinner so I actually wound
up having lunch with my friend Danny who
was employed in this whole situation to
make sure that I like didn't go anywhere
and was with her while everybody was in
the planning and I went to my apartment
dinners at 6:00 it was like 547 I texted
Zach I'm like where are you and he was
like crap and running late like I'll
just meet you there I'm like great so I
start walking over I'm like like this
could happen but like again I'm not
really gonna think about anything like
this could happen yes I was like there's
a chance but I wasn't like overthinking
you know it's just like thought in my
head I thought goodbyes thought so I get
to the lobby and Zach is there like all
suited up with no backpack and I know he
said he had a client meeting which I
since found out he didn't even go to
work nor do you have a client meeting
that he told me was horrible so like
liar liar pants on fire but I was like
ok little sketch again like when it's
happening you have no effing clue what's
going on even though you know what's
going on right and it's very quick like
you walk through the lobby in five
seconds yeah so we get in the elevator
and it just goes right up to the roof
again I'm realizing what's happening
that I have no clue what's happening
elevator door opens and there's a big
sign there that says will you marry me
and I'm just like so overwhelms I'm like
yes and he's like no it hasn't happened
yet I'm like oh you know cuz I hate
Dacor and highlight that what part was a
little confused yes so then I walked
outside where there's like people
sheltered but it's time because it was
like
yeah yeah we walk outside and because
there's like this grassy area all the
flowers and candles and beautiful set up
arrangement amazing I'm just like again
realizing what's happening but like not
because I'm so overwhelmed and mind you
like I'm holding my janky-ass broken
phone like my weird ass sweater and my
bag that has like my entire life and a
computer and everything I'm like I don't
even have the frame of mind to put my
[ __ ] down like that's why when you say
when you know you don't like I didn't
even know what what's happening but I
knew what's happening okay
so then like it's all happening I'm so
overwhelmed like I just can't believe
all that and like all of a sudden I
start hearing like a click click click
of a photographer and Zach was always
like I just want to let you know like
when we got engaged like we're not
having a photographer like he just so
anti all that stuff because he like we
could just live like in a little box for
the rest of my life and we'd be like
happy thirsty if the rest of the bunch
yes you didn't get that thirst DNA
strand but anyways I was like oh my god
babe I can't believe you hired a
photographer like I was dying and then
all of a sudden I saw that it was Zach
sister taking all the photos she like
loves photography and she did such a
beautiful job and I was so happy that
she was a part of our moment it was just
like so sweet it was just like I was so
overwhelmed with emotion and like in the
grand scheme of things I'm an emotional
person but not that sort of emotion it's
usually like emotion sad not emotion
happy do you know what I mean yes I
understand what you mean I was so accept
like I not to make this about me but
like wow that's what's happening and I
knew you were up on the roof like I
couldn't breathe I was like freaking out
I was like I just I couldn't take the
anticipation anymore like it was it was
so much like himself overwhelming just
like waiting you guys were up there for
so long
I wanted to come down and Zach was like
wait I thought like something else was
happening so like we were just taking a
lot of time up there but like the only
thing that I had said to Zach is when
you proposed to me the only thing that I
want is that immediately after we can
see our families and that's why I know a
lot of people thought that I was gonna
get engaged in Napa like I knew I wasn't
because I said like we have to be able
to just be with everybody after that was
the only thing that I asked for and
that's why I always knew we were just
gonna have like
chill very like sentimental family
oriented engagement not like a big
splash which I'm the most okay with so
like that's why I just knew it wasn't
happening in Napa when everyone's like I
thought like no I knew I wasn't yet I
also knew that it was gonna happen
before Thanksgiving that was a timeframe
that I had in my mind so that's why
every day before Thanksgiving that could
possibly be I was like today could be
the day very fair so did you have like a
manicure at least so I did have a
manicure because like I actually do get
a manicure quite often like for people
who work in the corporate world let me
give you a little tidbit like go on your
lunch break because one nobody's there
and - it's like a good kill of an hour
and three if you're somebody that's
dieting like I am right now then you
don't have to sit and think about this
that's true and also it's the perfect
amount of time and if you're also a
working person you should have manicure
like it really spruces have to look
totally but I will say something I
people nowadays it's like you have to
make sure she gets a manicure before she
gets engaged like you know she wouldn't
want to put the ring on like a chipped
finger and it's like it really does not
matter because even in all those
pictures that you took like you don't
see your nails and like you don't care
about your nails yeah I got a manicure
right before cuz like Snitch was making
fun of my mint green nail polisher like
at the time I was happy that I did but
in hindsight like if it's at the risk of
spoiling the engagement like don't make
someone go get a manicure you know
because it's a telltale sign once I was
like let's get manicures I hate your
nail color yeah nobody said that to me
but what people did was I swear to God
never in my life have so many people ask
me what I'm doing this weekend no one
ever asked me what the heck I'm doing
because I'm never really doing much
unless I have a big plan whereas like
everybody knows where I am
I'm going on somebody's that's red or if
I have a wedding or something like
everybody knows like what I'm doing that
weekend so like really random people
were like what are you doing this
weekend and I was like why the [ __ ] do
you care so then I was like ooh peace
peace peace like adding it all together
you know they're [ __ ] yeah some
people they think they're so sneaky and
they're not yeah no you're not you just
gonna be quiet well the other thing is -
and so Zack Zack and I went to look at
rings so like I knew pretty much what I
wanted because I have a significantly
large finger which is like the size of
like a seven and a half it's your left
ring finger the double-jointed one or
your right one they both are oh my god
you guys this girl has the craziest
fingers like you're just like Bob around
but anyways and it's so funny actually
this is a really funny story because
this is the hand so this is my hand okay
when I was this must have been like 10
years ago now a piano fell on my hand
like a full-fledged baby grand and my
two fingers here mostly this one were
completely shattered okay not a big deal
went to this hand doctor specialist and
when I put my hand in the x-ray for some
reason like my joints here like this
finger just naturally separates like
that like they didn't even realize that
my two fingers here were completely
shattered they thought this finger was
broken like that this was the broken
part because my finger my hand is so
insane your hand look at my hand is so
insane like my pinky just goes out like
that like I don't even know why it does
that your hands are wild like they'd so
anyways because I eluded me so because
of that because of that I actually
wanted to have a better understanding of
what I wanted to just know what shape
looked good on my thing right and I
never thought that I would want around I
just didn't think it was my personality
my face is round enough and I got enough
rounds in my life that I was like I
don't think round is for me but when we
started trying everything on like I was
like oh I'm into an emerald I'm into and
I was trying everything on and it just
was not doing it for me and I tried on
the round and I was like you're gonna
think I'm nuts but there's no doubt in
my mind like this is it and so how it
happens it's really nice like a portal
and makes a choice for you like if you
go into the ring choosing process with
no clue what you want like me like I
didn't know what I didn't know anything
yes II cut emerald cut like oh nothing
and I just tried on a bunch of rings and
then I'd had like no reaction so yeah
this is a beautiful ring what's not to
like and then I tried on like the one
and I was like I'm a princess and she's
like that's how you're yeah and I
actually always thought I wanted an oval
and I always thought I wanted exactly
your ring yeah and what's funny is I
actually started following a lot of like
jewelry Instagram so there's a girl that
I went to NYU with her name's Olivia
Landau and she does the clear cut and if
you're just like wanting to know things
about diamonds her Instagram is amazing
this is like not a plug at all I'm just
like I think she does an amazing job and
so like I would really like get a good
understanding of things are
even like message her I'm like what is
something like that like cost what does
someone like that how long does it take
to make I just like wanted to know like
what if things were cuz I didn't know
anything right
and so after second I looked at the ring
we basically like I made a promise to
him and I was like I and I'm not this
type of person to begin with but I was
like one like I'm not touching your
phone until it happens like I just won't
pick up your phone won't look at your
phone won't nothing I didn't want to
know anything got it I was like I'm not
gonna try to be like the great
hypothesize er like I just like we made
that promise to each other he's like we
went to look at rings you know what's
happening like just like let it happen
and that is what we did got it because I
was like you're kind of like sneaky and
on top of things like if you wanted to
know you would have known exactly and
the other thing is - the only time I
ever saw something was Zack was driving
so I took his phone we had to open a
note and in the note I saw October 12th
and I said to him I'm like I just want
to let you know I saw this because like
like I'm a very honest person I was like
I don't I know whatever you guys are
doing like you're working super hard
like if I see something I accidentally
I'm just gonna tell you and he was like
actually like that's Claudia's show
schedule like he had Claudius goat whole
show scheduled to be able to know like
when people were in town and when people
weren't and then I went on girl with no
job comm and saw that oh girl no job com
shameless plug she's an ammonite go by
techno
Alban here Alabama Albany Albany you're
right Albany called an album yeah
yeah she didn't push it a story before I
got here about someone bringing her a
real tied shirt but like she's not going
there for another day days she does have
a show on October 12 and then I was like
okay this is about as much sue thing as
I'm doing that's a fact that's a reality
goodbye great well it all worked out we
are so happy for you like satin the
whole weekend was just like so wonderful
and full of love but just like seeing
anyone and seeing you act like you're
happiest yeah it was just like so lovely
to watch
well we then did have a surprise
engagement on Saturday night with all of
Zach's friends all of our friends which
was just like a blast in the glass like
I think everybody everybody told us that
they had truly the best time it was so
fun yeah it was so fun yeah it was just
like such a good group of people
honestly like not to toot our own horn
but we just like surround
with good people so we do it's nice um
anyways we're gonna take all your
questions for Olivia after the news of
the day so we can break it up we have
some really good questions for you
there's one that I just actually want to
ask you first because oh it really
sticks out to me um are you gonna wear
platform sneakers at your wedding
yes so this is an amazing question I
almost put it on my story so I found
these shoes I'll show them to after
everybody knows that I wear Selig
McCartney's I have now four pairs of
them in addition to like all bunch of
like that people could lift that leg by
the way he said you should probably see
my face when I did that because number
one I've been working out with Matt from
the lives method who's like literally
the greatest trainer on earth my body is
so sort I couldn't I just couldn't lift
my leg right now like I can't move it's
just like working out such different
muscles because like I need all the help
that I can get then I'm starting as
early as I possibly can take a day one
of being engaged you're heading for the
wedding I'm shedding hardcore and like
the workouts are so great if you don't
know about the live method one I really
thought that like I should work with
somebody that like had live in their
name I just felt like it would be La Vie
II know it's Li B it sounds for live
jeopardy and vitality and it's amazing
he started the whole business on his own
him and his wife are so freaking cute
their Instagram just like amazed me like
the transformation set people go through
like people that I know through people
and I'm just like always was wondering
like how did they look so good at their
wedding and I was like oh like this guy
like really and all the trainers that
they have they're like bus people's
asses like in the best possible way so
how often are you going to train um
right now I'm planning to train two
times a week but then they do like group
circuit training bootcamp classes on
Saturday and Sunday I'm not going this
week but I plan to be there every week
going forward so like please come with
me at the live it will be so much fun
like everybody's more than welcome like
we'll all train together it'll be
fantastic and so yeah I'm super sore I'm
really excited I'm hardcore shredding
for the wedding if that was a question I
will answer that now Shetty and Miranda
will go back to my other question
because you will be wearing platforms so
I found these sneakers which I won't
lift my leg again because it will
actually break this time with white lace
instead of the pink part they're a
little too expensive a lot too expensive
for me right now but I have a million
surveys
don't hurt me yes they're gorge Indiana
1111 if you wish for them you'll get
that I just I'm not like gonna spend
money I'm like a pair of like Jimmy Choo
Carrie Bradshaw with the because I'm
gonna wear here for two seconds and burn
them and I just would rather be me and I
will be wearing white because I knew
that was a question to well I would love
in my heart of hearts to our black I
just will not and which is why I didn't
wear black on the show today in addition
to the fact that it woke up at 9:10 so
that is you are wearing black this is
like a navy blue oh no no this is black
whatever there's no limit black what I'm
if you're watching the colors are a
little skew cuz my shirt looks at like
hot pink but it's actually what do I
look like on there it looks like yeah I
guess it actually looks sort of gray
compared to your pants but my shirt fun
fact is neon orange so Bruno Mars which
we have to talk about because you
literally lived your bestest life ever
I'm in love with him okay so for those
of you don't know I went to the Bruno
Mars concert last night and what's so
crazy is a year ago Claudia and I were
supposed to go to the concert and I fell
ill but I gave my tickets to the snitch
and I just felt like Miranda Bremen I
felt like Miranda Priestly's assistant
when she can't go to Paris because she
gets hit by cab and like she's been
eating cheese cubes all week and Andrea
size six gets to go so I would like in
my head I was just like you know what
the next time he comes to town like I
will go and I will see Bruno Mars one
time eventually and I just want to say
like really patience is a virtue because
I've been patient and it was a year to
the day that he performed at Barclays
last time which is just weird
like we're never rain so I went with
Zach last night and like we just like we
tried to get the best foods possible I
was like I he's my one of my favorite
artists of all time like there's no
amount that I wouldn't spent to see him
right so we just wanted to be as close
as possible in it and like he is just
like so wildly talented like his music
is so good like everyone was up on their
feet the whole time like people of all
ages it was just like such and what's so
crazy I forget where I saw Bruno Mars
say this he was like I was on a cruise
once in Hawaii and there was a band when
he was a kid he was like they were just
playing music that everyone wanted to
dance to and he was like that's the kind
of music I want to make like everyone
everywhere any age like whoever you are
can dance to this music like he's really
accomplished that like
in Spain who opened for him so it was
supposed to be cardi B right but then
she dropped off the tour and now I think
was like a mix of people I don't know
who did it last night but I didn't go
for the openers got it we had a
delicious meal looked at a Bellini as
like that which is a new trip Rihanna
restaurant at the Seaport and like I
just was feeling not well all day like
mentally and physically like I just did
not have a bad day so I was like I need
pots I need to fuel up for this concert
and even when I got to the country I was
in like kind of a bad mood because I was
just like not feeling it like didn't
even bring a portable charger cuz I was
like there's no way I'm gonna be like
filming and being extra the whole time
right yeah the first note of Mike power
music like it just totally transformed
my mood well have you ever been to a
concert and like you obviously hold your
phone in your hand it's about someone
like you and look at your steps after
that's all I do so yesterday I
accomplished 4,500 steps which was all
from the concert because from once I got
home from the tonight I didn't get out
of bed like just like really wasn't
feeling well right um but then just
Bruno Mars totally lifted me up and if
you ever have the chance to see him go
and see him it was just such a great
show music for everyone you know every
word to every song and he's just an
amazing performer an amazing dancer and
like I [ __ ] love the hooligans like
his group they're like they're so cool
and I want to be a hold it in the way
that I dance like I've got hooligan
vibes it's like they're not like they're
amazing dancers with amazing rhythm but
they're not doing moves that like could
break your back be like a hooligan for
Halloween oh my god I should be ideas of
what you want to be for Halloween I do
um a couple of solid ones like maybe Kim
Possible maybe me some ramsey right I
have a list on my phone right um Zach
and I still want to be like Annie and
Daddy Warbucks one year but like I
assume it's also like kind of morbid you
know no it's like just weird and funny
but I don't want to wear that like wig
like that well you wouldn't have to
you're just kind of like have somebody
really your hair like super like good
night oh baby girly fun another fun
fashion as you know I hate Halloween
I think minimize no no no you hate
Howell I hate Halloween
I never go I don't dress up I never have
I don't care I don't get it I'm so glad
it's in the middle of the way
so all you [ __ ] can figure out what
weekend you want to do before or after
and go away yeah that's very I'm Brad
cream Joffe into Halloween just not for
me and it's funny because I was watching
the Food Network last night was just
super on Brad for me and everything is
Halloween themed and I just like I
couldn't even wrap my head around the
fact that like we're close to Halloween
you know I mean Halloween is around the
corner
it's what's crazy is on October 26th
like Christmas programming at Hallmark
starts like I couldn't get super down
for I'm so down for that I already
watched a hallmark movie the movie the
other night it wasn't Christmas themed
it was just like love June weddings and
was called June in January and it was
really great i highly recommend um and I
recommend Bruno Mars and I recommend
getting engaged
totally I really recommend getting
engaged - so now that it's been I didn't
even mean to just from scratch my head
like that with my finger but here I'll
just keep doing it for you why do you
need to apologize I don't know I know
it's just like cuz usually I wouldn't
like put my hand in front of my face but
yeah you're so aware of like oh yeah now
that we've killed 23 minutes here are
the past five stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast wonderful
question for you yes do you watch the
toast as I said I think I said in
another venue on the patreon maybe that
I don't always get the chance to watch
but I mostly try to catch up on podcast
on the way home which is what I learned
of the home and oh are you like a back
spasm Laurie I'm like really actually
not feeling I'll tell you guys that's
why I like I didn't really you look you
look fantastic and you do not look like
you don't feel the power of makeup but I
woke up like with the sore throat I'm
getting sick and like if it were any
other guest I'm like what it cancelled
well I would say one thing after this go
home go to sleep with no air
conditioning on and just let yourself
sweat it out you'll feel so much better
when you wake up okay but I also should
take something but then I'm getting on a
plane tomorrow which is gonna make
everything worse totally but I'm super
excited for you for my big my big photo
shoot totally it's gonna be unbelievable
does everybody know yeah everyone knows
I'm going to State Fair this weekend to
take engagement pictures they're gonna
be so bad I believe what's so crazy is
right now like I chose this date like
months ago I could have gone alt like
the State Fair is a two month thing so I
just had to pick a day that like worked
for me and Zach and Anthony Vasquez and
love them so dude Oscar the weather now
let's make is amazing
it's like still like bathing suit
weather and of course like the day I'm
planning to go there's like 70% chance
of rain but I don't let the weather like
affect people know also the State Fair
is very much like 10t vibes red and
white and wait get under with the rain
like gorgeous no it's gonna be their
notebook if it does rain like it'll be a
pain in my ass but I'm not gonna let
that stop me from like totally what I've
been finding like a full-glitz god [ __ ]
yeah no because I like I like I do
makeup but I will be bringing like full
glam um anyways sorry
glad to know that you watch the toast I
listen and honestly there's some guests
that I like tune in to more than others
okay so as it relates to the stories I
have a pretty good gauge I'm like how
you feel about most people and most
things so like I don't always feel and
all the stories that have ever like been
in your life I'm pretty sure I've known
most of them right so like I don't
always feel the pressure to watch all
the time it's more so like I just like
to be informed as all the other toasters
are but I actually had a little bit of
anxiety coming today because Heather
just kills it she kills me and like to
follow her that is hard no it's so
different she's what she was saying
about orbits like I can't even because
you know what I totally agree but I've
also been that person who's been zone
six who's like complain that I can't get
my bag on because at the end of the day
no matter how much you spent for your
ticket you bought a [ __ ] ticket no
but like there's only so much room in
the overhead okay
then figure out overhead to seat ratio
based on the size of bags that you allow
on a plane like it's mad okay so only
allowed smaller bags and then your bag
doesn't get up at all no my bag fits
just fine I always make sure I got it up
and I feel like you don't book through
our berths like you're always getting
upgraded through Delta
I am always getting upgraded through
Delta but like sometimes like orbits and
all of those Expedia Trip Advisor not
like I use Google site Google flights is
the best of everything and it's not
orbit so you don't get put in zone six
you just got put in whatever yeah
wherever your seat is yeah so no so
she's but this is just a totally
different show because everyone's been
waiting to hear from me Oh totally how
much anticipation hasn't been building
so it's just like we don't need to come
here yeah but she's got jokes I just got
me do you know what I mean go great okay
okay first story very exciting news
shots of sunsets Mercedes Abid is
pregnant inspecting her first child
inspecting expecting her first child
with husband Tommy
fight okay you guys this is so cute and
so sweet and I love them Mercedes Abid
is going to be a mom the Shahs of Sunset
star is pregnant with her first child
with her husband Tommy fight a source
confirms to Us Weekly exclusively the
source adds that chubby told her mom the
happy news and then the cast of shots of
sunset while filming the reunion on
Thursday October 4th the Bravo star 44
opened up to us in July about freezing
her eggs before the pair tied the knot
she opened up to Us Weekly and she also
opened up to us in July about freezing
her eggs so she's been going through
this process for a long time trying to
get pregnant and she's finally had
success and I'm so happy for her she's
been so open about how difficult the
process is and I feel like a lot of
people were able to relate to her and so
like just to see her like having this
success yeah and be able to talk about
it freely now cuz enough time has passed
like I just couldn't be happier for the
two of then her and Tommy are fantastic
like just seeing them in real life is
like they just go together so well I
really am so happy for her I don't watch
a lot of Bravo anymore but like I just
like certain people and I actually
follow her on Instagram because I just
like find her to be just like there's
something about her that she's like so
irreverent and like just real like I
love her I couldn't be happy for her
honestly like I'm in the state of like
blissful happiness and I just wish
blissful happiness on everybody in the
world and whatever that means to you
take it in and I know that this is what
this means for her so I just I my heart
goes out to her I'm so happy
totally and then we're gonna have a
little shop baby so that'll keep next
season pressure I haven't been keeping
up with this season I sort of like
dropped off I don't know why I don't
even know what night it's on like
totally I feel like it's always on
Sundays no maybe that's why yeah that's
when I watch II I was taught an ad in
the street that was like four CW and
it's like Sunday's therefore the CW and
it's like like no it's not not even
close
it's like Sunday's are for E and then if
I'm not watching he might feel like I
could name us literally ten other
channels before I get to this totally
and I feel like the CW is only on like
Wednesdays when Riverdale's on and I
don't even watch ever Dale and I were
and I would know that right and like
dynasty if they put it back to back with
river daily on which they should
Wednesday Sur for the CW but then they
move dynasty so Friday and I don't care
dynasties could be on like I don't know
what blue blood Saturday night and I
would stay in to watch in season one has
been on for
nice which is like such a weird night
and it's been so successful because it's
just such a good job maybe cuz it's like
a family show and like you watch it on
Friday night Daniel I don't watch it I'm
gonna get on board I'm the only one in
the family no way I just like I'm okay
for now oh oh you're gonna also like you
guys like love those cop shows okay I've
been watching Blue Bloods it's like it's
driving brothers when he comes home
sweaty and he's like I was watching cops
like I've every blood since season 1
episode 1 like I was in college
literally 9 years ago like in my dorm on
a Friday night watching Blue Bloods
before we would go out and all the
sisters whenever they would make fun of
me about the weird [ __ ] that I would
watch on TV they would call out to
things so like you watch weird things
like blue bloods in the black list and
now everybody watches Blue Bloods and
Margo watches the black list too so I
guess I'm not that weird no I called you
out for watching weird things like the
Food Network and that's not weird um
what's the other thing the affair
everybody you watch like everything ok
travel hot hire Chicago Fire is a
fantastic show like the this is us you
watch I've been keeping up but it's not
it's not my favorite because it's
getting if the first season was really
good and then they just like had a lot
of pressure on them and I just kind of
felt like it was getting a little like
phony forest and also I follow me
anymore on Instagram and like seeing her
like get into it like I'm not loving her
the way that I was in the beginning
because they just like I find and I read
some blinds about her the whole thing
anyways but Chicago Fire is fantastic
everybody under the plot under on earth
watches the affair and I even I haven't
even watched last season at the affair
so far ok well oh it's all so hard it's
like there's so many new fall shows on
on these networks and some look good
like some look terrible like a million
little pieces or whatever some look good
like manifests have you seen the
commercials for that one it smell the
plane that went missing for five years
and it comes back and everyone like
looks it has an age today and they're
like in perfect you know what happened
last see I get a tuck everlasting lost
but it looks really good and it's like
everyone said the first episode was
really good but I don't want to get
invested in a show that's gonna be
canceled right I and I agree with that
and also it's fun to watch shows that
have more than one season like I'm
watching The Good Wife right now which
has eight seasons it's gonna take me
through the end of the year and I'm very
okay with that do you remember when we
used to watch how to get away with
murder yes I just like I said
- I couldn't watch week to week because
it was just too suspenseful and too
scary and I would watch it before I went
to sleep and it's like who needs this
I've already seen room yeah and by the
way and it's on ABC so it's like it's
not even real scary because I can't even
do that much like why are we afraid it's
just like the music is dark it's so dark
so you hadn't like you have to watch
with the lights off yeah because it's
like dark like Game of Thrones but Game
of Thrones is like less scary like I'm
not worried about like White Walkers
coming for me in my sleep like but I am
worried about murderers okay
next story is very exciting speaking of
fall being upon us pumpkin spice latte
season started in August but is
officially here and what's interesting
is the number one state for consumers of
the PSL is you want to take a guess
mm-hmm New Jersey no that's a funny
guess though because they're all like
basic [ __ ] right sorry
love you guys okay by the way exact is
from New Jersey so we're a long podcast
in New Jersey
not for long anymore I'm really sorry
you guys moneybags can I get another
guess yeah I don't think you'll get it
it's kind of random random mmm so random
I'm gonna say like Arizona no Oregon oh
I was never getting that yeah I don't
know why what the rhyme or reason is but
square took a look at PSL transactions
from across the country last year at
small businesses that use its card
readers it found that after Oregon
people in Wisconsin Ohio Iowa and North
Dakota drink the most pumpkin spice
lattes when adjusted to account for
state population okay so it's like
percentage that is but it's not a
Starbucks pumpkin spice spice latte it's
just in everything pumpkin spice latte
because you don't pay with squared at
Starbucks mm-hmm so it's like if a local
like a local coffee makers making it
yeah bird that's interested interesting
Vermont and Maine where September and
October are all about foliage
surprisingly drink the fewest number of
PSLs that like sort of makes sense
because all you do is look it's outside
to get into the season like you don't
need to go drink a PSL whereas if you
live in California and you want to feel
like it's fall like go get a pumpkin
spice latte I just have or light a
candle you know everybody can eat and
drink whatever they want but pumpkin
flavored things are gross and like
especially I don't want to start my day
with anything pumpkin flavored period so
like I don't get it respect that you can
drink and eat and do whatever you want
but like
I don't get it I have to be honest I
never tried a pumpkin spice latte no but
have you had like pumpkin flavored
anything like it's not gonna buy not
your favorite is it it's nice from what
I've heard pumpkin spice latte tastes
like chai latte which I love and I don't
start my day with a chai latte because
like then I would be like morbidly obese
right um but if I could I would I do I
do I would have it like as an afternoon
snack with a little kooky cookie krisp a
pumpkin flavored cookie a pumpkin
flavored cookie with a pumpkin spice
latte sounds delicious now I know what
all you guys in Oregon are up to and if
I could I would square also says that
the cheapest version of the beverage can
be found in South Dakota where the
average PSL is three dollars and 56
cents okay that's so price and the most
expensive one is in Tennessee where it
cost about five dollars that is so crazy
it's like the details that we can get
about pumpkin spice lattes like we
should probably be using this
information to like get a man on the
moon in person but there has been a
madman what about a woman on the moon
hell yeah I think you should go
volunteers tribute I get too homesick
like I really would like I can barely
leave the country without like being
like where am I Who am I why is the
toilet flush like this so imagine me on
the moon no no totally also I don't know
about that outfit I don't think is your
style you know the spacesuit I don't
know moon boots love them moon boots I
just got a new pair of movements that
are the key to thing you've still been
wearing moon boots for ten years now
since college yeah and like they're so
you know who really started the moon
boot rent Paris Hilton other than her
like somebody we know hey Danny Handler
she had them in every color shape size
I'm pretty sure when you came to visit
us freshman year like she was wearing
them and you're like oh that's cute I
can wear those and then you went off
really I I need to think about where's
like nuts about them every color where I
was first introduced to movies I got
them freshman year of college I got pink
ones they took me all through college
and like when it we used to know at
Colgate like it would be but you would
like if it wasn't a snow day which would
have been like a million inches like
just a normal day would have been like
up to your knees and snow and the moon
boots really just cut through all that I
had some good times at Colgate yeah in
the snow
junior year September you came with
Danny that was wild we went to beta be
ya know but I also came another February
when all of your friends were abroad so
that must have been jr. oh yeah and that
without you so you came twice that you
got really sick whatever yes of course I
remember and then senior year you guys
came for my birthday and then he also
came in June for my graduation
yeah because honestly we didn't come for
Jackie we came for slices pizza which is
literally the best foods on earth the
best things on earth and I heard a rumor
that slices is closing and I'm literally
freaking buy it by the recipe and run up
and bring it down here I mean honestly
it's a very what's so crazy is like
everyone who goes to college is like my
college is the best food like I don't
know I can't notice I can go to Michigan
like shut up seriously shut up and like
my sisters who like don't feel strongly
about anything like and if they do it's
pizza and like their New Yorkers so
they'll tell you New York pizzas the
best pizza like agree that slice is
equity is the best pizza of all time
there's no doubt right so it was there
it doesn't mean so much coming from like
a college student like coming from you
guys that Slayer is true no doubt no
doubt
so I'm so glad you agree I'm going to
call Nate in a month you are yeah I'm
going with Rebecca Andy now we're just
kind of fun weekend with our men then
like show 405 yeah where are you gonna
stay at the Colgate it and very
prestigious oh my god that's amazing
yeah we do all those things that like
you couldn't do remember there was like
a country club type place like yeah yes
though there but it's a golf course and
it'll probably be too cold
but they have a delicious like the fancy
things you know yeah like people go like
apple picking and stuff I'll think about
it you know you're fine
I just like kind of want to just walk
around take a pic totally will say that
go to the library read a book I don't go
to Frank go to Frank oh my god yes okay
next story very sad news Zach Brown it's
so hard for me say he's at Brown without
say exact Ron man yeah
but Zach Brown of Zac Brown Band and
wife Shelly separate after 12 years of
marriage quote this was a difficult
decision in a joint statement shared
exclusively with people the Zac Brown
Band lead singer and the Shelly Brown
jewelry designer revealed they are
separating after 12 years of marriage
quote we feel blessed to be on such an
incredible journey in life and sometimes
the journey begins to lead in different
directions
it is with deep love and respect that we
announced that we are separating as a
couple said the pair who Wed in 2006
very sad very saw the Browns share five
children Wow son Alexander four
daughters Joanie Georgia Lucy
justice justice for these children man
totally very very sad very sad but like
you know hopefully they'll be better off
happier separate totally and I know like
one Zac Brown Band song and like I feel
like every summer they sell out Citi
Field and like the most like wild
spectacular concert and good for them so
for country artists to do stadiums in
New York he's wild most country artists
can't even do MSG in New York because
like New Yorkers are so out of tune with
what's necessary true mom might be a
pricey divorce son yeah oh for sure
no he's definitely rolling in it but
she's a jewelry designer sleek maybe
she's lovely for her maybe she has her
own stuff that is very sad honestly I
hate to hear that yeah you know me too
but maybe this I mean silver lining
maybe this will spur in some good music
from him totally if he writes his own
music
he definitely does I heard he's writing
with Ryan Tedder from One Republic and
like that's gonna be amazing because
he's on tour with One Republic right now
God when Republic's opening for Zac
Brown Band which is just like something
I never would have thought of but I did
you see one Republican concert recently
yes when I went to see that I'm
surprised like how many of the songs you
knew and you really liked them right I
knew that like I loved them and I was so
excited to see them and then they were
just even better I was surprised
actually that they were the opener and
that like less that it was just it was
just that was surprising but I got it I
don't know good squad I got it
anyway it's very sad story but very saw
let's move on to an even sadder story no
yeah man rescued after allegedly being
kept in a squalid six-foot shed for 40
years this is just so crazy because you
know that we're in like room mode this
week have you seen room I haven't and
Ivan honestly yes this week I know what
happens and I choose not to watch it I
mean what do you obviously we all know
what happens right I just like I know
the premise and thus I don't need to
torment myself for exact that's my felt
yeah I'm sure cinematographer lipika Lee
it's wonderful and the acting I know she
was nominated for a zillion awards and
Jacob Tremblay is an angel from heaven
but I still choose not to watch that
movie like it's not about all those
thing at least for me it wasn't about
like the cinematography or whatever like
how great can you shoot a six 11 by 11
foot shed but it was more so about like
the the thought-provoking element of it
and like what it means
like them to like be in the room and
then get out of room spoiler alert and
how they like go on living their lives
and like you know she had a child in
room and like what that means you know
no total it's just a lot to think about
yeah and I'm still thinking about it and
I think that you'll be thinking about it
for a long time and thus I'm choosing
not to put myself in a situation to
think about those things well here think
about this okay an English man has been
rescued after allegedly spending the
last four decades living in an unheated
shed in a case authorities have
described described as quote modern-day
slavery on Wednesday gang masters in
labor abuse authority discovered a 58
year old man during a raid at a
residence near the city of Carlisle
which is locating and located in England
but is only about 10 miles from the
Scottish border in the shed which was in
extremely poor condition the man was
found with only a chair and a badly
stained bedding we found him what we
found him he was like a rabbit in
headlights and very confused Martin
Plummer
from the GLA a said in the statement
obtained by the BBC quote he was just
enclosed he stood up in and where he was
sleeping in the shed there was just a
solid soiled duvet on the floor Plummer
told the outlet there was no heating and
it was very cold it was conditions that
no human being should be living in
clemmer and the GL I believe the man
began working as a modern-day slave
around the age of 16 or 17 BBC reported
the information that was given to us was
that he had been kept in the shed for a
period of 40 years in my long career
I've never come across anyone who has
been held as a slave potentially for 40
years and this I think could be the
longest period of captivity that we have
dealt with it's an extremely sad and
serious case so sad that is so sad there
are photos of the shed and like alright
I can't get a chant we've just been like
talking about like kidnapping situations
all week and like I guess this is a
kidnapping week I guess and so maybe now
here I'm glad this man has been
discovered but like well there's two
elements of it one that he has been in
captivity for like 40 years
and thus like essentially a slave for 40
years which is insane and to just like
16 or 17 like I can't even wrap my right
leg and then if you like go out into the
world now 40 years later you've spent
like majority of your life living like
this how do you adjust to the real world
that's like what
some of the conversations sparked in
room but at least in room they had a
toilet a sink and a TV which had really
kept them occupied this man just had a
bed and I can't I really don't have much
to say because it's horrendous it's like
so horrible like I'm gonna be thinking
about this guy all day no I'm so glad
he's freed but I just like where do we
go from here was his family looking for
him like how did they even find him what
is the situation of these people that
were keeping him captive I'm sure more
details will emerge will file the story
closely okay there's a final story some
business news which I really feel like
more encouraged to speak on now cuz I've
been hearing so many success stories
from people about like this girl
messaged me yesterday I'm not gonna put
you on blast but she went on a date with
like a man who's like older an
established attorney and they're talking
and he was like talking about business
stuff and she was using like she
mentioned something that we talked about
on the toast about Elon Musk and how
like he's a creative but maybe he's not
meant for like the business side of
things and the guy she was on a date
with most like so impressed she was like
I think he fell in love with me like in
that moment so I just want to like put
more news and stories out there so that
you guys can be sparking like
interesting conversations and just
really like I don't know changing
thinking that's well-rounded us we
possibly can be changing the dialogue so
kind of get any worse for snapchat stock
falls below eight dollars after analysts
cut price target snapchat alienated many
of its fans including some celebrities
when it launched a controversial
redesign of the app earlier this year
that's not what did it by the way a CNN
business and if you want a business
expert Harvard Business applicant to
come in acharya like and see that's the
type of [ __ ] that like i wish i watch
the toast because then I found out all
that no oh my gosh I'm applying to
Harvard Business School okay
I luck on the GMAT I have my Pacus
becoming student gonna take one I have a
practice book do you want it
well after I spent like $29 I guess well
I did it no otherwise I would have given
it to you because at one point I was
thinking about going to business school
and I bought the book they're gonna go
to law school well I was gonna go to law
school media after college but then once
I started like being in the working
world I thought about going to business
school and then I thought about getting
my JD MBA
cuz you're my law school score like
laughs for a pretty good time even
though it wasn't very good
where would you have gone to business
school I didn't think that far I thought
more so about the GMAT and what like I'm
not the best practice test
um I took some practice sections because
my this is my plan I'm sorry you guys
have to hear this again but some people
just don't want to toast um I'm gonna
take the practice test if I get below
with 500 I will give up on the stream
because clearly like I don't have time
for it if I get above I'm gonna work
towards getting a better score and
applying to Harvard and then I think
everything else about me will get me in
okay I'll I agree and then like this
show will really like we'll have like a
Harvard business mind on the show like
well it'll just everybody gonna relocate
to Cambridge and like go to the show
from there well it's like we're the we
are the number one podcast in
Massachusetts so it wouldn't be like the
worst thing I'd ever happened to us and
you know maybe I could be like a
commuter student I haven't totally
figured it out yet if you went to Yale
you or Princeton you could truly be a
commuter student because the Train is
only an hour and a half versus Boston
which is a bit further so if you really
want to think about doing it
legitimately you could think about
schools also NYU Stern is like one of
the best business schools in the country
okay but you know NYU Stern just doesn't
have the same ring to it as Harvard
Business like but I'm not gonna change
the room not going to business school
I'm going to Harvard fair fair but what
about Princeton I mean I guess I would
go yeah I guess it's not arm twist my
arm and yell fine I would think about it
raised anyways
CNN if you want me to for him oh yes I
would go to what that was context our
fifth warrant and we're the two now and
I think would be a really good option
for you because you could legitimately
do the show and like make it to a two
o'clock class no totally and like this
show would still benefit from awarding
this and again learned how to drive you
could drive yourself back and forth no
problem I just say let's start with the
G mats okay okay um anyway CNN if you
would like a Harvard Business School
applicant to come and explain to you why
snapchat is below $8 I'd be happy to do
it it reported a drop in daily users in
August and now it seems Wall Street is
giving up on snapchat as well and it
seems like everyone's giving us not
giving up on snapchat as well like do
people still work there does Evan
Spiegel still go into the office or he
just like is with Miranda Kerr and their
baby great okay so this is what I have
to say about snapchat because I too work
in media
it's so funny because a year ago people
would have like died to be given the
opportunity to work a bank job like I
remember we're like jobs in snapchat and
it was like oh ma you got like the
golden ticket to Willy Wonka's factory
and now it's now you're the grandparents
and the but this is why and we've talked
about this a zillion times one they
didn't listen to feedback and they just
let Instagram copy everything that they
did without like evolving and changing
the platform as they need it to and to
like there being too many things too too
many people right now like just become a
private messaging service for these kids
that want to like send weird photos back
and forth to each other like look at
your data how are people using it ain't
nobody watching discover all these
brands that killed themselves to get on
discover that have so quickly loser
losers like it's so stupid like why
would you even hire people waste time
energy and effort to like build out
these like vertical formats when nobody
was watching did you even look at the
data to see how many views you had
before you kept pulling more money into
figuring out how to get on snapchat
besides the point go to snapchat like
were you looking at the data to see like
people were active dentally finding
themselves undiscovered only watching
the Daily Mail snap story by the way and
realizing that like ooh this is not our
business people do want to just share
with their friends they don't want
brands to engage with them this way it's
just like no one was like being smart
there and looking at everything
everybody was like kind of just like
intrigued by like this new platform and
that's what peak peak peak peak peak but
like they didn't actually have a
business plan to sustain no for a long
time like they were innovating in a way
that like that we needed because first
it was like a weird messaging app where
people like we're sending nude photos
and then like they introduced stories
which really like made it a whole social
platform on its own and then they did
nothing about Instagram copying them
they like did not innovate and like
Instagram happy to you so you should
copy the things about Instagram that are
good like tagging friends that took time
like at least six months to do totally
different fonts like making it easy put
like just stupid [ __ ] like that would
literally take a programmer 30-second
Pinterest save like that took seven
hundred years to get right so just not
it was a classic case of not in tune
with what's necessary yeah and it's like
they got so big and then they were like
let's just live off the land
and not try and innovate further and
that's why right now the shares of snap
sell more than six point five percent
Thursday to an all-time low after two
analysts mark May of Citigroup and
Anthony DiClemente of Evercore is I cut
their target on snapchat to seven
dollars a share it's now trading below
eight dollars and has plunged more than
forty five percent this year DiClemente
who has a lovely last name that I just
love saying DiClemente
who keeps tabs on download activity
expects will snapchat will post another
decline in users when it releases its
third quarter earnings later this month
or in early November he said the
redesign has been a particular problem
for me for Android users
yeah the redesign was just like the
cherry on top yeah the Sunday of
disappointment was already there listen
snapchat got greedy they wanted to just
partner with brands and make money they
didn't really think about their audience
and their base first and if you look at
Instagram as an example Instagram has
never really been focused on the revenue
portion of it slowly but surely they're
adding ads and shoppable experiences
like over time everything is beta tested
with a group of people they think would
be interested in doing it they were
willing to test screenshotting and
everyone was like no no no and they just
stop that snapchat you still screenshot
and everybody gets an alert like they
didn't put their users first they put
making money first and that's they I
totally tanked
I actually just I feel like they didn't
put making money first at all they like
they're like Netflix they just are
spending all this money thinking it's
gonna come back to them but because they
weren't like doing it in a way that was
smart like the money never came back it
was like there they were never really
making that much money well if you think
remember that Rihanna added like they
were just willing to take money from
anybody and like throw ads up on their
discover do you know how much brands had
to pay to like get on discover to like
they were just like throwing [ __ ] up
there because they were like oh come
come come come come without singing
about the implications long-term in my
opinion I feel like the ads that they
did were actually like fine though cuz
they were doing like sponsored lenses
which were actually becoming pretty cool
like ugh this was cool but what my
makeup brands and movies and all I feel
like that was good they what they
weren't doing enough advertising in a
way that was smart I feel like Instagram
is so thirsty with the advertising like
I see like the craziest [ __ ] sometimes
but I'd be like that's a symptom of
Facebook it's probably a symptom of
Facebook and what I do on Instagram is
ijen if I see an ad I literally hide it
say I don't want to see this content and
honestly I barely ever see any ads in my
feed because I personally chosen to have
my experience be the way that I want it
I don't mind the ads like I understand
this in the necessary evil this is a
free app like just like this is a free
show and if an ad were to come on like I
know you guys would understand and I you
know we live in a capitalistic society
like make that money totally just
deliver premium content and everyone
will be happy and snapchat was not doing
that henceforth drops below II know I
honestly I haven't opened my snapchat
app since December of last year so I
never let them delete it so that in
their next quarterly report they have
that accounted for because I don't want
anybody to take my user name so thus I
just continue to leave it there just the
app itself it's hidden in a folder
somewhere like it doesn't bother me okay
okay all right there okay now it's this
time that everyone's been waiting for
I will be asking Olivia all of your
burning questions about life love
business and the pursuit of happiness
and of course the pursuit of happiness
okay let's see what is your go-to
karaoke song this one is about the
pursuit of happiness by the way I
actually don't really have a go-to
karaoke song but it would be any song
that I actually know all the words -
okay fair what kind of music like is
your favorite kind who's your favorite
artist to be honest with you I like a
lot of different types of music and it's
really all dependent on mood to be
honest with you my Spotify does a really
good job with my daily mixes and so like
I mean I can either really be in the
mood for like David Guetta or like I
could be in the mood for like Maren
Morris and I have a weird obsession with
Madison beer and those are you do I love
her who's someone if they came to town
like you would spend any amount I be
front row have to see them I don't know
that's what I always think about because
you guys like die to go to concerts and
I'm always like yeah like I don't really
care to go like I would just go to be
with all of you not like go see the
music yeah it would probably be like a
John Mayer just because like I like have
loved him for so long and like know all
the songs and I love Coldplay and I like
love them for a long time and loved all
the songs but like I don't know I'm not
like I'm not the biggest concert goer
yeah like I go for fun you know and be
more hurt no I'm alert and that you
invited me to Bruno Mars and I was like
nah
Thank You free ticket you offered me
free tickets and I was like no I was
like oh my god okay um anyways people
want to know that your job okay because
you still work at oh yes I do
um what are what is your day-to-day like
yes how was that going my day-to-day is
good and my job it's actually so funny
so I do influencer strategy talent
marketing and a lot of like branded
content video series sort of things and
I was doing that and then I moved into
more of a social media focused job and I
was helping do some of the corporate
stuff in the interim but there's been a
lot of changes at oath and I'm since
back doing you know influencer and
content development so it's very fine
it's a job I mean I think what's funny
and I read some of the questions to
where it's like how did you become such
a boss woman and so like I'll just
answer that question now now but when I
graduated from college I had started
interning at AOL and I had taken the
LSAT twice and I really thought that I
was gonna go to law school but everybody
encouraged me to get some like real work
experience before going back to school
and so at the time a o-l was a publicly
traded company and I thought great like
this will be my check box for working
you know in the real world and then I'll
go to school they no longer a publicly
traded company
well now Verizon is publicly traded but
we're like a private entity inside so we
don't necessarily have to report
earnings every quarter like we used to
have to I'm sure I'll be learning all
about this at Harvard yes you will and
so anyway it's just like when I got
there it was just like so excited by
just digital media and mobile content
and all the sort of stuff and I was like
wow like I really want to work in the
space and like I got the same score on
the LSAT I was like maybe this is a sign
I'm not doing any better like I'm not
gonna get into a good school so like
what the heck am i doing let me just
stay here and figure out my life so now
I've been at the company which has since
been through about 10 to 15 different
acquisitions obviously acquired by
Verizon I've been there now for over six
years and so I've just had a host in
many different jobs and I think you know
I really like put my whole life into my
career like I thought my career was like
the thing that was gonna do it for me
and I was boss woman I used to travel
the world and blah blah blah and like I
always put my job before myself and I
had somebody who's like a mentor to me
to me at work who said he's like I just
want you to remember like your job is
never gonna love you back like you
should start really thinking about like
putting yourself first like you should
get some love in your life
like when I met Zack and just like knew
from the start like this is what I
wanted my career has like I don't want
to say like been put to the backburner
but like at the end of the day like you
have to put yourself first like it's
true your job is never gonna love you
back like you can invest everything in
the world into your job but like you
only go there from 9:00 to 5:00 right
what about the rest of the time what
about your weekends and so like I feel
like I have so much of a better balance
now where it's like great a job as a job
and like my personal life is so just
like so poppin off in such a positive
way that it's like great whatever
whatever jobs you need me to do like I'm
happy to do but on the other side of it
like I'm just so happy when I go home
like and just being in my life that like
that's where I invest even more of my
time because there was a time when like
you were like even more of a business
woman special thing you are now like
totally lived together and worked at the
same company and we never saw each other
cuz you were always like being the
Traveling Salesman and your own spilling
those devil's Starbucks cups no well it
was like it has on the top hello now my
hair is gonna smell like coffee all day
but there are were things yeah um you
were in the Traveling Salesman and
advertising salesman yeah and like I
worked in advertising at that point now
I'm in more so like entertainment but
yeah right so you just like your whole
life was work and now my whole life has
changed
and then so much for the better I think
I always naturally have within me this
like businesswoman spirit like I'm the
oldest right like my job is to just like
take care and be in charge like this is
just like how I like to have you program
right but at the end of the day like
that can't be all you're about and I'm
so glad that like I've reprioritized my
life to not be all about that totally so
some folks want to know how did you in
that meet this is a such a great story
but no it's I'm Zach and I met on a
dating app when I saw him I was just
like hey which one for any hope hopeful
romantics out there sure we met on J
swipe it is a Jewish dating app and when
I saw him I was just like that's one
like I have to meet him like I just knew
from the second I saw him he was just
he's my type to a tee like this just
like big hunky man and I'm just like get
in my life right now so we were
messaging back and forth I like couldn't
even believe me mad so my hot
and any looks like I'm traveling for
work well like let's get together when
I'm back so I gave him my number and he
never texted me and I remember my friend
Marnie's bridal shower we all went out
after for this girl's birthday and I
just like you know had a good amount of
drinks and I got home and I was just
like whatever happened to that guy I was
just like hunky one like I need to find
you so I Remus age him which by the way
I would rather drop dead than ever
message somebody twice because if you
don't put in the effort to reach out to
a woman I just like don't want to hear
from you like not I mean that's not my
kind of person right I was just like but
you know what there was just something
about it I really wanted to meet him
from the second I saw him I was like I
gotta meet that one that I was like okay
you know what I'll do it so every
message Tim how were your travels like
I'll never forget it because like I
don't talk like that do you know how are
your travels you don't not talk like
that yes or no things in which to snack
but that wasn't me that was Danny for
sure but you do that too now because
like we were saying yesterday Megan
Markel lives with the royal family she's
feets British you live with Danny you
speak things everybody know the things
in which to stock I'm sorry our friend
and former roommate Danny like we were
talking about the way that she speaks
and she's extremely articulate but also
like the roundabout yeah that she said
so there was like a hurricane coming and
you guys went we're like going we went
to the grocery store to get food because
obviously to stock up and so she was
like let's get things in which to snack
instead of just being like let's get
snacks like yeah it's just very just
like became the defining example of like
when you use too many words which I
definitely do I talk in like marketing
jargon but like I wouldn't be in a
workplace it's a valued thing because
the longer you talk think the longer the
meeting is people think you're severed I
think of where you're talking about
totally but anyways how are your travels
spun into a text conversation where we
plan to go out the next Tuesday and at
that time I actually didn't know that
doc was living in Philly he had moved
there for the year for his job but he
had signed a lease like three weeks was
moving back to New York so I was like
you know what fine like three weeks not
that bad I'll figure it out
so we were supposed to go out that
Tuesday and I'll never forget because
that Monday night he canceled on me
because in his mind like he was on the
apps as a formality to never really plan
to meet anybody on it which was like the
same way with me where I was just like
I'll just do this so people get off my
back but like I don't know if I'll ever
meet anybody
why so he canceled on me that Monday
night and I won't forget it because we
went to watch what happens live to see
Daniel I Colts and I was just like Zach
and I like the text conversation just
like popped off and we were just like
texting the whole time me Mom
at watch it up inside it's like such a
great night but I'm like on my phone
talking to this stranger that I haven't
met and then that Thursday we went on
Claudia's Bachelorette to Vegas and I
was texting him the entire time like no
one even knew I was like texting
somebody that like I hadn't met which I
didn't tell anybody because like we
hadn't met yet and it was weird
and we said I was staying in a room with
Danny and she was like to the stage she
was like like I saw you on your phone
like smiling but like you weren't on
your phone where it was like
all-encompassing like what are you doing
on your phone you know it's just like so
natural mind Dru like I'm on about
surrett where I'm not like you know I'm
raging essentially and it was just like
so natural ain't fantastic and when I
came home that Sunday my friend Brittany
was like one thing that I recommend you
do is like always talk to somebody on
the phone you can get such a good sense
of somebody when you hear their voice
and so we spoke on the phone that night
till 4:00 a.m. Monday Tuesday Wednesday
talked all day all night till 4:00 a.m.
every night on the phone we finally met
the Thursday like from the second I saw
him I was just like oh my god we went on
a six-hour date we had way too many
drinks we had the absolute best time I
went to the bathroom I texted my friend
Danny and I was just like I know for a
fact I'm on the date with my husband I
am on a cloud right now I just knew it
from that moment and then the next night
Zach wound up staying in the city just
so we could go out again where we went
like on another six-hour date that we
just had the best time and like then he
went home for the weekend but came back
money Monday he took me to dinner we've
just like really truly have been like
inseparable ever since and so I just
like knew from the second I saw him I
knew from the second I met him and so
that is essentially how we met that's so
cute so what are some of your guys's
like hobbies like what are things that
you guys like to do totally we love to
watch TV together we love to drink wine
together we love to cook together we go
on like a big five to six mile walk
mostly every weekend like we just like
being together zach watches a lot of
football like tv's like three fantasy
football leagues ipod ipad iphone like
anywhere that it can
it's streaming so I've since grown to
like football as well but mostly we just
like like spending time together and
doing things together no matter what it
is very cute switching gears yeah if you
had to choose one sister to go on The
Amazing Race with who would it be and
why
snatch why my wrong answer by the way
really yeah I'll clean okay I would
choose Margot because one she's
extremely in shape and likes to move and
would be willing to just like do the
hard work and to you know we live
together so we have like a good
partnership in terms of like how we
divide and conquer for sure the correct
answer that would be me was like I I
have high Treach levels and it's so it's
like I would do the physical stuff it
would be hard for me but I would do it
all because like I I can and like I also
have like the street them like the
street smarts and like I could get us
out of a precarious situation like I
think I would be an all-around
I would be a good player at all of the
different facets as opposed to just like
really strong at one okay um so uh yeah
I I accept your resume and I think about
it and you're thinking I love her let
her let me know and I will I'll circle
back and I'll let you know by end of
week thank you which is in an hour what
does a day in the life of Olivia look
like a day in the life of Olivia looks
like I wake up or is this like a weekend
or a weekday I think weekday okay I wake
up as late as I possibly can which is
probably 8:30 at the latest I rush to
get dressed I always go to Starbucks
there's two Starbucks in the city right
now that are super convenient to my life
that I go every day and everybody knows
my order what's your order it is a hold
on let's see if I can read their
language a venti iced coffee single no
she's not so good she's engaged jingle
means an extra shot I need it to be a
bit stronger no classic sugar-free
vanilla extra ice two splendas light
cream half and half a splash oh okay
would you like what snow classic classic
is that simple syrupy sugar they put
into instead of that I get sugar-free
vanilla got it yes and a lot of people
who listen to the patreon heard my order
and also now get the Olivia and people
are loving it yeah for a start
for Starbucks it's pretty good and I
have to say I don't actually like the
taste of Starbucks coffee but I have
been drinking this drink essentially
this way for so long that it is just now
like part of my routine and I like this
God you know what I mean I don't know if
you like coffee I don't even like star
but I just had like a cup of coffe but
it's not like something I crave when I
wake up in the morning I just need this
like this gets me through my day so
interesting I just need coffee I don't
even like it but I have to say recently
I've just started going to like some
delis in New York City that have just
like hazelnut iced coffee and very good
but it's the deli because sometimes the
coffee smells like a deli no it depends
on the fact of how many other things you
need because you need to hit a 5 or $10
credit card minimum of course yes um how
has it been living with Snitch oh I
didn't finish my day oh right we only
got to share coffee yeah because if a
lot of people want to know okay so the
table the snitch guitar I grab a coffee
and I usually like uber uber pool via to
work I go to work from around like 9:30
to 5:00 and then I usually come home
Zach and I will cook and we will watch
The Good Wife and then go to sleep I'm
so hungry
you're making me hungry okay um I'll
cook for you ooh what do you must come
over to your apartment we should have
dinner and I'll cook that would be nice
do you have pots and pans
I have pot great one hot that's always
hot and I have pet correct
do you have spoon and I Fork oh yeah I
have some nice okay I got everything
else I have in the rest I'm registering
for it okay cool how has it been living
with Snitch when are you moving in with
Zach and what's gonna happen to be
snitch okay great that's an amazing
question because Zach and I have
actually been looking for an apartment
out for two months and you found one we
found one the paperwork is in but we're
renting a condo so it takes a while to
get approved by the board but
essentially like all these things are
just happening at the same time which is
chaotic and madness um but hopefully we
will be moving in the next couple of
weeks and Snitch
I will miss her dearly she has been a
wonderful roommate we just you know lay
in our separate rooms and don't talk to
each other sometimes we eat dinner
there's nothing better we eat dinner and
then we go our separate ways you know
but um just she's like
you know she weeks of the morning I'm
like hi like she just like that person
that you're so excited to see when you
wake up she is a good roommate in the
sense that she's dependable she's
reliable she's fun she's always down
like go out to dinner order in dinner
like she's just like you know you don't
have any roommate problems with Snitch
yeah
could she be a little tidier sure could
you sure of course but I also as I
mentioned before like I'm in the
business of taking care of people and
things so like I don't mind it for sure
are you ready to be mrs. out tibia
Shapiro oh yeah I am are you gonna
change your last name we were talking
about this I am gonna change my last
name it's so funny my friend Danny got
me a jacket that says mrs. Shapiro and
I've been like wearing it around like
I'm married oh my gosh looks like I
would literally get married on the side
of the road tomorrow like we could very
well get married tomorrow and like it
would just be no thing like we just want
to be married I like call him husband
like would you ever elope I wanted I
mean I just like would want people that
I love to be there but there's like ten
people that I love so it's like not that
big of a group but I'll go I'm super
ready I'm I just feel like I was like
born to be like a wife and a mother and
just like continue to take care of more
people and just you know be in charge
for sure be in charge of the household
you know like I was born for those
things totally yeah if you could have
any singer perform at your wedding who
would you pick and what would be the
song that they sing that's a great
question if it goes back to like my
general law I curiosity about your music
tastes alive we think you did ago Dead
Billie Holiday I would say Frank Sinatra
obviously because Zach loves Frank
Sinatra a great song is Frank Sinatra it
just it's such a hard question like I
genuinely don't know I really don't like
I I just that he's so crazy I just like
all music like I really do like some if
it's a jet like a Bop I'm like I'm jam
out to it you know it doesn't have to be
by a specific person like I don't wait
with like bated breath for like Lauren
Alaina to drop her new single which is
apparently amazing and I'm so happy for
her but like at the end of the day like
I'll listen to anything you know mm-hmm
there's I mean Jess Glynne is of every
song as a bomb like I just love her too
but it's like I don't necessarily choose
her do you know I know interesting this
is very what do you choose oh my god
where would I even begin um-hmm I mean
maybe Bruno Mars singing like just the
way you are and to marry you for my
wedding would be like really nice
I will make a baby ellie goulding which
is a weird choice but I love the song
love you
let me like you do love me like you do
like I think it's a great love song I
could go for Christina Perri like twist
my arm
sure I don't have to say probably Josh
Groban yeah sure you can perform I'm a
big lady a fan like I've seen that
that's the only con I've been nine times
so I can actually say that probably them
like I love some of their music so much
and my friend matt has always taken me
and that's just like been our thing and
so probably like I I mean I wouldn't pay
any amounts of money to see them because
I've seen them so many times so I'm
stumped okay you stumped me love it how
will your wedding be different from mind
we have different bride styles and those
what kind of bride do you think you're
gonna be totally um I start with that
because I'm curious I don't know and
someone else asked his question like
have I been the type of person that like
dreamed up my wedding my whole life no I
have not been it's not my personality
like I'm just like I am like in my mind
I am simple and like classy traditional
with like a pop up pizzazz that's like
what I imagined for myself right like
when everyone's like what's your decors
style I'm always like white and black
with a pop of color like that's just how
like it's very Christian or two so
that's just how I imagined myself I
think honestly I think will be very
different but like in a very
complimentary sort of way for me the
only thing is just like I want to be
like more in charge yeah you want more
it's like I would literally do all the
planning all the everything myself like
I wouldn't want somebody to plan my
Bachelorette for me like I want to do it
myself
like right just like these are genuine
like things that I enjoy doing I enjoy
doing them for others and thus I will
enjoy doing them for myself so do you
think you're gonna be more of like a
bridezilla than a bridezilla I'm gonna
try really hard to be I think like
there's no reason to be a Zilla when
you're just like happy and everything's
going great but I think also like
planning a wedding is a lot there's a
lot of things that like we're both super
fortunate that like Claudia did it and
she is the best about everything she's
like I'll get you this I'll get you that
you need this you need that like she's
so amazing about that so like for us I
actually think it will be easier where
we won't have to be zillah's because but
I feel like this isn't even about the
planning it's like are you like some
people are just so crazy
about like specific things like I don't
want it like that like why is she being
this way like this you know what I mean
yeah it's just so like look I'm the type
of person that's like honestly like wear
what you want look your best does this
work for you like because at the end of
the day if there's gonna be tension then
like it's not gonna be fun so yeah I'm
not gonna be Zillah about those sorts of
things will you know I'm not Zilla cuz I
don't like yellow people but I'm
definitely like bride like bride dress
up you guys stress up stress fear the
hell but end up so I'm not like chill
about it like let the chips fall where
they may
but I'm also not like being a Godzilla I
agree that just like bride xiety yeah
keep going bride's dress up right okay
then bride pit so you know there's a lot
of different kinds of bride satin could
be totally um how are you guys getting
along planning weddings at the same time
are you looking into venues caterers and
etc together well it's only been a week
so you're getting well but we actually
did have back-to-back meetings we did
with birch event design last week and I
was a little late and you must've left
early because I miss you so I heard that
you were coming and then you texted that
you were in traffic and I was like I
actually really have to go so I like
waited to see you and then I couldn't
wait anymore no I understand it and I
didn't even like I didn't even I wasn't
even like wait for me cuz I total you're
a busy woman no and also like you could
just call me and like we right if I
wanted to see you like I know where to
find a like totally um I will be so fun
like it just makes everything easier to
do it together like you you you do to me
like I called you about something the
other day and I was like hey like have
you done this like what are you saying
right and it's like if I have vendor
options for you like I'll give them all
to you and now there are things that
you're looking at and I haven't started
yet yeah and then you like sent me like
a video person the other day honestly I
haven't even like hearted looking into
that right total whoa because Marnie
recommended them to me and I was like
this there it's gorgeous and I feel like
it's totes your aesthetic and I was like
you would really like this like yeah I
have different styles that I'm like Leah
this is so Jackie and like ooh this
would be so me but like I'm open to
people's recommendations like hair
makeup band you know like we only know
like what we know and I'm down to just
like learn more because part of it is
just like the experience of like just
hearing bands and like seeing menu
and just like you know look and see what
you like and what you don't like I'll
recommend stuff do you recommend stuff
to me for sure um so that would answer
this next question do you think that
you'll have a bride war situation like
oh no definitely not
that movie Bride Wars I may be so stupid
but that's like tens like you know who
cares about their wedding that much well
first of all no one like plans their
wedding since they're six years old I'm
sorry that's just like not a real thing
I think if you care about your wedding
that much your priorities are off like
care about your relationship more like
care about your life in general more
versus like a party for one night no and
like your that was just so insane that
movie for so many different reasons and
like a wedding planner like that
Candace Burgess would never hurt him
yeah whatever I really like her oh hey
brown did you talk about that what's
that
that's just like a show from like this
70s that they it was another one that
like came back and I came back this week
missed my radar great I've never seen it
or heard of it until that so very
important question when do you and Zach
want to start having kids and then my
follow-up to that is who do you thinks
gonna be the first of the scenes to have
the first cousin I actually really don't
know but what I'm really excited about
is that they will really all be the same
age which will be just so nice and so
fun I think you know Zach and I are not
come on man plans God laughs Zach and I
are down to get married soon so that we
have like some a little bit more time as
a married couple and then just like
start popping them out but honestly like
we should all kind of like sit down and
like maybe like you should go first do
you think yeah I can okay I'm dad I
think Claudia Sam I don't think Katya
wants to be first okay so I think would
be between you or I but I feel like it
should be you okay great okay right on
that okay thank you
Ali no how drastic question if you guys
were offered a reality show about your
lives and relationships and work is that
something that you would do I know you
are probably the most private of the
scenes what do you think that's a great
question I think honestly and it has
been a conversation that we've broached
with people before I'm like so down to
do whatever it's really all about like
the partner that you do it like we would
need to do it with somebody that just
gets us that's not trying to make us
into something like if you just want to
capture like the real reality of like
what it all is um
amazing if you're looking for like an
edited like fluff fake version of
something no no for me it's like Bravo
or bust like I don't need some like
thirsty little show on oxygen um fair
like it's either like real deal or you
can scram I think I'm not that thirsty
for a reality show that I would do like
a liitle web show what I on MTV like
hoping it turns into something no I
totally agree with that and I also think
like it would be amazing just also from
what we would capture that we would have
for years to come like looking back on
it 20 years it would be like lazy
Claudius episode of saying yes they just
like I love watching toad like it's just
a memory it's such a good one that's
been captured and a beautiful wife for
sure but like now right now we think
we're so cool but like if we were to
film ourselves and then like look back
in 20 years we'd be like damn we were
embarrassing no we'd be like who's
literally like the first episode the
first season of Kardashians when Kim's
like my family has a lot of baggage but
it's like Louis Vuitton baggage like you
know she's so [ __ ] in marriage but
it's also iconic to the time right and
it's like so Paris Hilton I love Paris
Hilton still you know totally and you
just got to be true to who you are
um anyways final question I'll ask for
you okay because you are the
businesswoman special yes um what are
some like interview tips that you have
for the toasters because you know we're
a very like young professional community
here what are some of your tips for
landing an interview landing a job all
of that yes amazing question I thought
you meant interview and like this
setting and I was just like oh like how
do I believe it is my first time
co-hosting I am extremely weird in front
of the camera like yeah you're doing a
great job you are loving it okay good
I'm glad this is just like not my forte
but in an interview per se I think I'm a
little bit different in the way that I
interview or expect an interview because
for me it's all about personality I
think that you can learn anything on the
job but it's more so about if you vibe
with the person that you're gonna be
working for and the people that you're
gonna be working with because at the end
of the day you need to learn from them
and they need to learn from you if you
go in and like you love the job you love
the job description you can do
everything to like your aunt on the
people don't go for it and also like be
your true self when you walk in the door
so like they get a sense from you and
you get a sense in that I'm like the
reality is you spend a good amount of
time at work like you should enjoy it
you should enjoy
people that you're with like you
shouldn't always be looking over your
shoulder like worried about you know
people coming for you which does a
hundred percent happen in the corporate
world but if you get a whiff of that in
the interview probably not the right
place for you I think the reality is is
that persistence is key message people
on LinkedIn go to events ask people for
referrals like you have to put yourself
out there it did not just gonna come to
you and it's the same with like dating
you know like it's actually I just want
to tell this really quick story because
on Friday last Friday when I got engaged
I also found out that two people that I
matched went out and had the time of
their lives they've been out three times
since in the last week like this girl's
like I truly might know them maybe by
association and I'll tell you after cuz
I don't want to blow up anybody spot but
essentially it's a friend's boyfriend's
ex-boyfriends friends so somebody you
don't even really know with my friend's
friend we were on a Bachelorette and she
was like I just like don't meet any
great guys I dunno anybody for me and I
was like I know this like one guy like
third degree of separation he's saying
oh like we weren't even Facebook friends
but I messaged him on my Cadis is really
weird but like I have a weird feeling
that like I have somebody for you like
are you interested and he was like sure
and I sent the number and the name and
he didn't reach out for a month and then
he reached out and that Friday that last
Friday that I got engaged was like the
night after they went out and they just
had the time of their lives it was so
great and so like dating and
interviewing it's the exact same thing
like put yourself out there if this is
something that you really want and how
do you vibe with the person and the
enemy self because eventually like
you're the real yous gonna come out and
why I had wasted all that time
pretending to be someone else like
totally every company uses a different
system that you have to get trained on
that you have to learn how to get set up
with a printer like it's different there
you go so it's like you're not gonna
have 100% of the skill set when you walk
in don't expect to just be expect be
really aware of the environment in the
culture I think the worst part about
like having a job is figuring out how to
use the printers totally because like no
one ever tells you oh and then they do
and it doesn't work like it doesn't
connect totally I agree I even I worked
at AOL for like over three years total
and any time I had to print something I
sent it to you to pretty yes I never got
I did figure out how to use the printer
and
the print just fine right cos like they
teach you interns that stuff you know so
we were interning so you learned like
really from the ground up everything
about that's why I like working there
because like I've been in this it's the
same situation for over six years I know
the same people to go to to do this and
to do that when I leave my badge at home
like it's just like I created a
situation where like I worked really
hard for a long time to get to this
place to just be like really happy and
comfortable in that environment which is
so which is really all you can ask for
totally anyways thank you so much for
joining us Olivia and answering all of
our questions about that I could make it
here today right being here I love the
toaster community it's just you guys are
killing it I'm so proud of you it's it's
just such it's so wonderful thank you we
love the toasters to thank you guys for
tuning in today we will be back on
Monday I won't be here Claudia will be
here I think co-hosting with hashtag
snitch on the toes I believe - and
Lauren Burnham will be the guest so that
would be so interesting I can't wait so
interesting I don't I have some scoop on
that I need to comment my questions
because I like have so many for her and
I'm sad I'm not meeting her but I will
be serving a premium content from Dallas
so we will see you back here on Monday
follow me at Tokyo problems because you
know you really just shouldn't and at
Olivia are a premium content rhenium
content follow me as we shred for the
wedding business woman's special being
with the Steen's I'll be Beth I don't do
anything else so that's all you can
expect that's enough honestly bye guys
bye everybody have a great weekend
you